so let's correspond to all right here
for and dark souls is coming out on the
pc pretty soon right next couple weeks
yeah so mark made 20 april pointment
almost a month after the the console
versions and we have we've a look at it
right here so a lot a lot of work went
into making sure that this looked
exactly like it does on consoles except
the higher resolution what are you doing
to me nothing to touch me so my god oh
god it's a host prerogative just you
just have to let it happen and continue
like it this is am a set so the guy
wanna be I don't yet so I don't know who
these people are I guess they're other
press members like when I when I get
close I see the ghosts and whatnot so
there were some dude here just a minute
ago when I first came in but so I'm
hoping that I'll show something that
hasn't been shown on the show yet
because I mean people have seen it but
what I mean it's something that I
haven't shown on this show and if folks
have any questions at all for the pc
version of Dark Souls 2 for Kevin please
and send them on in first of all I'm
gonna ask the super obvious question
does this look better on a PC well it
does because it runs at a higher
resolution and it runs it at the higher
frame rate it's a good 60 frames a
second okay you know so but in terms of
like but intersex or the rest exactly
the same okay it's its platform parity
in the strictest sense of the term the
lighting model does not look like it did
in the pre-release questions that we saw
so people like that have been pretty
sensitive that that have seen the
comparisons between the initial showings
of the game and so forth but I'm gonna
have her move oh no she wants two
thousand souls and I don't even have
enough yield insufficient so it I'll try
to be as quick as I have let's see if I
have any souls that i can use in my
inventory no problem you're playing this
on a pod right now no I'm gonna go and
kill some things real fast all right
Marja she'll do a murder and all die
from it I'll just go in and kill
something real fast I promise okay that
I will see what I can get into areas
that we have yet to so first question
comes in from cyp view asks how old is
medicine keyboard work with this game
you're playing on a pot at the moment
yeah I am playing with the pad at the
moment because I still
ultimately it's better with a pad for
several reasons it plays ok on mouse and
keyboard um it much better than the
original for sure which as you recall
just showed the mouse pointer yes on the
screen all of the time which was
ridiculous and the key bindings were
stupid and now you can use a mouse and
keyboard just fine but you are said
there are even then there are a few
caveats though ok that I that I want to
make sure to mention one of which is
that you're always seeing the the mouse
and and or the xbox 360 prompts even
when you're using a mouse and keyboard
all of the prompts are really going to
be for for the xbox pc ok and also
you're still good if you want to just
use the xbox 360 controller you're still
going to need the mouse and keyboard for
doing things like for example typing in
your name ok to give it your name
because it doesn't have like a pop-up
thing when you're using a keyboard so
it's like okay well I'm gonna have to
get close to that I'll try to fill the
signal this big massive hulking dude and
while you do that I'm going to ask a
couple more questions abyss underscore
Archer asks what's the maximum frame
rate in fact Eminem stranger asked kinda
get higher than 60 I tried to lock down
at 60 like I think because when I was
running this it was it when I was you
know using fraps while I was playing it
was showing only 60 it never got over 60
I have two thousand so I'm going back
you can you've a look at the a at the
view there yeah let's take a look at the
view sure it's all pretty it is pretty
it's a great the highest tower flame is
a great place to to just hang out and
look at the view you know in terms of
Dark Souls 1 the draw distances are
better and so on and so forth I mean in
terms of the pure port yes you know it's
a much better port than the original
Dark Souls of a sense first one was was
and was riddled with issues in the sense
that this is what channel effects then
yes it's a much better port on the other
hand I fully imagine that the Dark Souls
community will be on top of this yes I'm
really quickly like though
that kind of stuff do you think well I'm
sure there will be HD texture packs
you've got our omelet for one I am going
to like so many of the questions we're
already receiving our bears like for
instance andrew is bored x2 asks does it
support 120 yards monitors like so much
of this game the community on the pc was
all about the minutiae of how this
looked and him had they get upgraded and
whatnot yeah yeah that was you know it's
gonna be interesting to see what what
Cole I missed this chest sorry you know
but any chance know I'll top your head
if it's a 420 hurt I don't know um but
my gosh i'm trying to think of what what
monitor i played it on at home but i
played it on actually i played the pc
version on my TV my old TV at home so I
i don't know that i have the exact
answer for you i'm sorry it does look
sharper though it look like you know
obviously it's a high resolution so
would but it's a higher resolution but
but here's an interesting thing we did
it we did a graphics comparison here IGN
to the graphics comparison oops wrong
thing no I don't want to buy that I was
close it was close i would have wasted
that so so but here's the thing like if
you if you drop this to 1280 by 720 and
ignore the framerate the game the game
looks exactly the same reddit on all
platforms there is ab there is it's
amazing just how exact it looks so if
you're a pc gamer that really wants the
extras you're not going to get a whole
lot of bells and whistles but again I
think we're gonna see the the community
get on top yep of this and I'm really
bad at talking and playing at the same
time at it oh I have a lot of arms to
share with everybody's walking through
these totally safe areas which is the
heart of the Dark Souls experience yes
but of course this is in this version oh
I this is the first I had to play a
bunch today because my save game at home
because I water the cloud and I could
not find for the life of me where the
save game file is kept or if it's just
like within the you know the actual the
actual Dark Souls file free keep
speaking of that stuff andrew is bored
x2 asks on twitch is their steam overlay
support is this Beatrice there is steam
overlay I was able to use the steam
overlay while I play dark souls pixels
not going to like because i don't have
the gift so let's go on let's activate
this it's not quite like ask him to give
you a gift or is that too forward now
he's not violate the etiquette of
strange men's like on your door now
Gabe's you need this gift for me to give
you my gifts whoa prerequisite for Gil
yeah it's a little strange it's like you
know in order to get my birthday present
somebody has to have already give you
their birthday present that's the way
the real world works Kevin I can't
forget a birthday present without giving
again some super specific nice questions
here Amadeo 8 on twitch is asking is the
cross region play restriction option in
the pc version you know what I don't
know let's take a look and see what the
the menus tell us you can invert the
access cross region play restricted yes
it was there was it yeah they're okay I
didn't see it it was above the bottom
three bars oh they're your right cross
region play restricted is it just
unrestricted restricted allowed I cool
voice changing here jump controls yeah
so you can she so this is exactly as it
wasn't in the consulship actually yeah
there's actually a different menu to go
in for for things like key bindings
where I had to look up certain things
because again all of the prompts are
xbox 360 controller prompts really I
using a mouse and uncle yeah so I had to
do a little bit of digging but I will
say this it feels it feels relatively
natural with a mouse and keyboard once
you get used to the you know a lot of
the Dark Souls idiosyncrasies about you
know how long animations take and so on
so that affinity on twitch asks how is
the port gameplay wise we talked a lot
about the graphics in terms of how plays
it's exactly the same which is to say it
you know it's awesome you know I think
dark souls you know too is an awesome
game I thought Dark Souls 1 was an
awesome game and on your help with a
little world ya gonna do that do you
ever play that pet you ever do those
that Perry game you know for Perry's
I've never been a big barrier in Dark
Souls and I'm fine with that because
just because of the way I play it Rea
says Harry oh so it's the fancy kind of
carrying out the kind of pairing you can
only get in a bottle really hit dude
bang whack crisp lat you've have you
been playing this game quite a lot on
various platforms like i have but then
the first time i'm really going through
this area on the pc so but how do you if
I is this a game you play for a long
period of time you still enjoying it I
love dark souls 2 yeah I mean I I love
the series I've loved all of the souls
games there's a reason demon's souls was
our game of the year shockingly / /
favorites like assassin's creed two and
uncharted 2 which came out the same year
so yeah I really really love this series
I i still am curious what would this
game have been if that you know the
lighting model we had first seen had
made it through would it have been more
atmospheric less atmosphere letting
model that you're referencing was just
like so much more in depth it was in
depth the dark was darker the the
real-time lighting really made you know
everything flickered and glowed like all
of the flames looked really remarkable
and it had a different look in a
different feel on what we ended up
getting I hope the same isn't the case
for is it below no what's the game the
game is using panta rhei oh I deep down
deep down yeah I hope the same isn't the
case for that because some so much of
the gameplay videos they've shown of
that or at least the technical videos of
that yeah show off how how like one
piece of lighting in a dark cave can
really add to like the atmosphere and
the and in ways the gameplay as well if
you're like using the light yeah and I
think heading into sort of the next
generation of consoles people were
saying like lighting is going to be one
of those huge places where we do see
those differences you know right the
complexity of the lighting model the
kind of ambiance I can create the the
depth of shadows and fog effects and all
this done all this dynamic stuff that's
sort of one of the frontiers in which
processing power still you know has a
long way to go and I you know a lot of
people I'm poison which is great boys
and I mean one of the things people
point out it's like hey graphics don't
matter nobody comes to dark souls for
graphics but having to die like and now
I know I'm trying to you can do us but a
lot of people you know oh god damn it
all good play Wilson
icing way to tie in the souls games
totally but in a lot of people you know
pointing out you nobody comes for the
for the visuals but you know as I
pointed out on a little twitter rant i
had today you know i think you know all
those things that we think of as
technical those things are also part of
the art design you know the textures the
lighting the you know everything you
know just like a painter uses do you
know acrylics or you know or our oils or
watercolor whatever you know that stuff
is still part of the artistic experience
and so I thought I don't think you can
really just remove those things from
each other you know obviously you know
you don't need necessarily the power of
the of tressfx yeah you know for what
happens I'll take a cool dark souls to
be with chess effects Kevin I'm gonna
interrupt you there quickly Roddy
you